yeah i don't know i i really enjoy
collaborating with youtubers and
and talking to them i think mainly from
the aspect of like you know i don't
particularly care about the character
themselves or who they're playing
yeah i think she's a content creator
myself i've had it really interesting
what it takes to play a character like
that permanently
yeah and it's normally you know when
when you talk to the
vtubers if i talk to them offline uh you
know you know you normally get some
really interesting uh bits of
information just about how
you know how they like prepare or how
they think about it and i just find that
really fascinating
and then i think you know when you're
collaborating with um
uh v tuber i don't know why i think
there's a really interesting dynamic
that you can work off really well if
it's one v tuber and one like irl person
yeah where although i think a lot of
maybe die hard youtuber fans would think
no never you know i'm sure yeah
yeah i think there is some really
interesting room for like really fun
and interesting collaborations that come
across because of the 2d 3d mix well i i
i completely agree because
um like i kind of remember when ladybird
was on like a few
now a few weeks ago i guess um but i
remember like hearing his story and
hearing how he
goes about you know his character and
his stage presence and everything like
that
i was just like yeah i kind of think v
tubers like i said youtubers were
wrestling with waifu's and after talking
to ladybird i'm just like
yeah i kind of i i kind of agree with
myself more now god cognitive dissonance
i found something that proves my point
thus it is correct no i do agree you
know i mean i
you know i spoke to plenty of youtubers
and you know you
you hear so many different reasons why
they became youtubers like
oh i just wanted easy money or something
no i really really like this character
i've always
or you know i i can't do anything with
my face i'm too anxious or yeah
everyone has their own reason and it's
really [ __ ] cool to hear about that
and uh
get to know the people behind it
sometimes yeah i i feel though like
especially recently like you know maybe
still in japan there might still be a
thing of
oh you know 2d and 3d shouldn't mix you
know like the irl
and v tuber should never do stuff
together because it breaks the immersion
wow but i feel in the west especially
recently i feel that
idea is slowly starting to fade because
especially you know if we look at like v
shojo right like they're doing a lot a
lot more like collaborations with irl
stream
like jana's did that whole thing where
they did a tour of japan
yeah right yeah and that was irl and uh
i think
just yesterday as of us of of this
episode
um anthony padilla did like i spent a
day with v
chews yeah yeah yeah we actually had a
they actually had a clip of trash taste
of the cali episode on
oh really on that on yeah yeah and i
just feel like
at least in the west you know there's
sure there still might be a lot of like
die-hard
chipper fans who don't want that
illusion to be broken or whatever
um but i feel the majority of them are
kind of just like well
i mean let's not kid ourselves right
like these are
also people and you know i think it's
cool to see this like
really weird two different worlds
completely clashing with one another in
a really
cool way because like i i will say like
i have been watching less youtubers
as like 2021 has rolled around right
part of the reason of that is that anime
has gotten really really good again so
i've just had less yeah
but sorry scripted waifu
back to the scripted one back to the
scripted ones
um but also it's it's less that i've
just been watching less youtubers but
i've just been watching more
streamers in general now and not even
watching streams but watching like
the stream highlights in the stream
content that's been posted on youtube
um because i feel like there is a
definite difference between
hololive and v shojo right because i
feel like v shoujo
are v tubers who are streamers yeah and
i feel like hololive is
definitely more like treated as idols
yeah
and it what i what i what i found is
that i kind of more gravitated towards
seeing
the uh not uh youtubers as content
creators like i i just i just respect
them as content creators
more than anything and like i you know i
i've never understood idle anime or like
the idol
kind of industry itself so that's why
i've gravitated more towards
youtubers who i think i just like beyond
anything are just talented content
creators and yes
and just doing good content and i think
that's might be one of the big reasons
why
nowadays i'm watching a lot of streamers
from niji sanji
because again like it's not so much they
kind of treat their v tubers
again like streamers like actual content
creators because they don't
they're not really seen i'm sure there
are people who view new signs of
youtubers as idols quite unquote but
yeah i feel
just been in like a lot of live streams
of all sorts of different ninja
scientific creators they're definitely a
lot more just like
just people like streamers and content
creators who are just here to have you
know just
just shoot the [ __ ] and just have it
yeah yeah i mean like yeah again like i
feel
there's like a different type of
enjoyment to that as well as you know
how
whole alive is kind of seen in that
sense i'm not saying one is better than
the other personally but i just think
it's like a really interesting dynamic
because
people just think oh if you're a v
youtuber you're immediately like
whole life or you're immediately like v
shojo like you're just kind of
thrown into this like single basket of
you are this type of content creator
with this type of fan base when yeah
in reality it's very very different
depending on how you
i guess treat your character yeah you
know
even in hollow life even even in the
whole life agency itself there are like
a lot of a lot of streamers in hollow
life are doing like very very different
content but i think the difference is
now
that you know 2020 was the year of the v
tuber yeah or or whole lives year right
because it was just like they'll be like
the zodiac the year of the
youtubers
yeah yeah i mean 2020 was the year of
the v2 yeah i don't feel like the hype
is
you know i mean obviously the viewership
is still there but i think that the
craze that was there the growth
yeah it's definitely going to be harder
uh to grow as a youtuber yeah
even in an agency like hololive now
because there's so much competition out
there it's like the gold rush is already
like yeah the golden age is kind of over
right and i think this year has really
for me separated
like v tubers not just youtubers but
streamers who are doing like really
really
interesting content and just interesting
ideas
versus you know you know a youtuber who
you know
doesn't like doesn't put as much thought
into their content maybe and just
yeah you know um i was trying to find a
way a nice way to work that
the good ones from the bad as everyone
no not not the good ones from the bad
but just the ones who
the stronger ones the ones who really
view this as like
as as content and just like as an
entertainment platform
rather than not just as like a gimmick
right yeah yeah exactly because i feel
like the gimmick part is over now
the gimmick era is over and if you want
to grow as a youtuber now you
need you need to have solid content
right and i think it's because like
you know the the idea of v tubing as a
gimmick now is just so
just common knowledge now that yeah
whenever a new youtuber comes out
not as many people are like oh my god
did you see this like
it's like a virtual person on my stream
right now like yeah everyone knows what
a veto is now